Peter King on the phone line right now
his football morning in America Monday
column is must read stuff and he joins
us back here on the show how are you PK
rich the amazing thing about that is
when you look at Washington you know
obviously I don't know how many people
expected them to basically be two games
ahead in the loss column of Philadelphia
right now but the amazing thing about
this is that you know a lot of times you
can look at a team schedule and you can
try to divine what the rest of the
season is going to be like sometimes you
can figure it out
sometimes you can't but I mean you know
Washington's schedule is eminently
manageable particularly over the next
three weeks and I look at it and I
basically say this is this is not out of
the realm of possibility in any way
shape or form now that Washington you
know wins this division or at least is
very very strong in this division down
the stretch yeah I and you you can't and
certainly they've got a steady hand at
quarterback and then running back Adrian
Peterson Peter I mean nobody wanted him
in the end the offseason and he he's
been dynamite he's been terrific he's
the old AP the ad all day he's running
all day I think I think he he was so
intent and he was so angry I talked to
him I don't know maybe three weeks ago
and he was so you could just hear he he
kind of keeps his anger bottled up I've
never heard him you know really kind of
cuss out anybody or anything but she's
like so many athletes he uses the
slights from you know from from anybody
the perceived slights the real slice to
basically motivate him into what he does
and so I kind of look at them now and I
say you know this is real possible you
make the point about Alex Smith look you
know at some point the chief said Alex
Smith has a limited ceiling so we're
going to draft Patrick mahomes and so
they did work out well for four
teams really I think this trade did and
as I look at it right now Alex Smith
could could really be the kind of
quarterback he could be 95% of Kirk
Cousins he could be a hundred and six
percent of Kirk Cousins you know they're
not really all that much different
except probably in the ability to throw
deep down the field more accurately in
cousins case but I look at it now and I
say this is a this is definitely a
contending team Peter King here on the
Rich Eisen show let's take the other
teams in that division one at a time
right here starting with the Cowboys it
certainly feels the way that the games
ended in Houston on Sunday night a
couple weeks ago and then this game
where just only two plays with 52
seconds and a timeout in their back
pocket were able to be squeezed off for
a 52-yard attempt with a five-yard
penalty that was as bizarre as they come
it just feels like this is the last
chance finally for Jason Garrett in
Jerry Jones's mind how do you think it's
it's well I would you know I think
sometimes we talked about Jason Garrett
like he's the Marvin Lewis of the NFC
and I don't necessarily think that
that's the case if you're around the
Dallas Cowboys and you see how they work
together and you see basically that that
that Rod Marinelli is coaching this
defense and putting up a really good
representative product year after year I
mean this is not quick I don't think
it's automatic that Garrett goes in
other words I think it is more likely
than not that he goes if they go 6 and
10 or whatever but rich I would agree
with you the clock management in the
last two weeks has been poor period he
obviously should have gone for it last
week instead of punted back to the
Texans and he should have gotten more
than six yards out of the last 52
seconds or whatever it was but having
said all that to I mean that was a
horrible horrible call Tony Dungy said
it on football night last night I've
watched it a bunch of times I watched a
jp-la do sewer press thing afterwards
and I did look it up this guy has not
had a
since 2014 on that snap why all of a
sudden when you snap the ball the same
on everyone why why do you get a penalty
called on you at an absolutely vital
moment of a game that just might decide
decisive it well and look and I am and I
am I am a Jason Garrick defender and and
you are right I mean look the way that
they have been playing on defense I know
Rod Marinelli coaches it but this team
is a cohesive unit it does appear and it
does get better on at least one side of
the ball but there just seems to be
clock management issues and also just
that Prescott has totally regressed and
whatever you know ingenuity that we see
in the home games including that Jaguar
game that was between Houston and
Washington it just seems that the same
problems crop up when when the games get
toughest and and who else do you have to
point the finger towards because it's
not gonna go towards the general manager
that's for sure that's the only point
that I'd like to make on that front as
you said rich you're right but just
remember one thing just like Mike Brown
with Marvin Lewis the entire free world
can think this is a bad coach they got
to get rid of Marvin and they got to do
this it just doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what anybody thinks in
the outside world because Mike Brown
really doesn't care and I'm not saying
I'm not saying Jerry doesn't care he
cares he cares what people think about
his do you think about his team no
question but this isn't like a lot of
teams where the owner sticks his finger
in the air licks it and sees which way
the wind is blowing to see if he's going
to keep his coach or not Jerry Jones
you know he's gonna really have to be
slapped in the face this is a guy who
kept the same coach 2 3 3 3 6 and 10
years remember and so I I just I'm not
convinced that this is it I think it's I
think as I say it's more likely than not
if they finish under 500 that this is it
but it's not a certainty yeah there's a
bye and then their next two games are on
national television Monday night at home
against Tennessee and then at
Philadelphia on Sunday Night Football so
it's
it's a it's only gonna get hotter the
seat if there are no wins and then
Philadelphia I know we could just chalk
it up to hangover that's what we usually
do when a team doesn't play very well
after winning the Super Bowl or play
consistently but what can you put a
finger on with what's happened with
Philadelphia's we're getting set to see
them in London
next week I think there's a couple of
things number one I think that that
Carson Wentz isn't being protected the
way he was a year ago
you know the offensive line just seems
to be leakier than it was a year ago
even with Peters back I mean that's
number one number two remember last year
was a running back by committee with a
bunch of good backs you know now as I go
on I think that is that's hurtful and
then you know I also think that the
secondary should be better than its then
it's played I mean how he Roseman spent
a lot of grass capital I'll give you
Sydney Jones and the 17 draft in the
second round tore his Achilles he's a
legitimate top 12 or 14 pick in that
draft he has not come back and played
anywhere near you know very top NFL
corner level so I think you're able to
throw the ball down the field on them
and again look yesterday you know the
last touchdown the the the Philadelphia
Eagles usually don't get fooled on a
simple play like that when you're not
watching for Greg Olson to leak out from
the line from the one-yard line
knowing that the Philadelphia Eagles are
it can't really trust the power running
game of the of the Panthers maybe as
much as they could have a few years ago
when it was when they were more of a
power running team you know say Tolbert
and williams i mean you got to be
watching for Greg Olson on that play and
they just let him go Peter King here oh
sorry yeah sorry Peter King all that was
that really kind of bugs me about the
Eagle so when I see the Eagles as I
call the game with my NFL gameday
morning crew on Sunday in London against
the Jaguars who's the starting
quarterback for Jacksonville do you
think Peter Eli Manning huh I know that
you're saying that they should pound a
table you're pounding the table for that
Eli trade Oh
I mean look look I I would I would just
say I would just say this that my gut
feeling you know what my gut feeling is
they'll give bortles another game
because they don't really have much of
an alternative but bortles confidence
has to be at its nadir right now because
clearly when you hear Jalen Ramsey say
everybody knows what the problem is in
here we just can't say it I mean that is
that's a dagger through the heart if I
ever heard one
I mean what do you do if you're Marone
and Coughlin you got Jail and Ramsey I
mean do you say we will actually pay you
an extra million a year if you no
comment everything the rest of the year
it's me
it's just amazing what what he's what
he's doing but but I you know I don't
know I would I guess I would start
bortles and I I mean to me the absolute
killer for this team is not having four
net to take over games you know I'm not
saying he'd take over a game against the
Philadelphia front but he would at least
give you a fighting chance to be able to
run the ball competently against Philly
which is gonna be hard for Jacksonville
so I think it'll be bortles but I don't
have any inside information on it really
and then in that game the Texans really
put put it on Jacksonville I mean if you
want to if you want to come out and say
that that that's was for all the AFC
South to win that game on the road to
put the doubt into this team as deep as
it could be at the quarterback position
was remarkable certainly in the fact as
Glazer reported during the pregame shows
yesterday that deshaun Watson took a bus
and you put a lot more meat on the bones
I got glazed here tomorrow what type of
bus was it was it like a regular he
bought it alone
was a tour it was a tour bus I talked to
I talked to Watson yesterday it was like
a band tour bus you know a smaller one
there were six people on it or two
drivers a security guy at one of the
trainers and then there was the the
director of sports performance Luke
Richardson who kind of stretched and
treated Watson along the way they
stopped at a Fleming's in Baton Rouge
for dinner Friday night on the way there
and got into the hotel in Jacksonville
at about nine o'clock Saturday morning
and I asked the the Texans this okay
it's convenient this week because
they're home on Thursday night and then
he gets to rest for ten days before they
play Denver and I asked about you know
Denver's a little bit further Denver is
almost exactly a thousand miles from
Houston but I guess the doctors have
told them that that it should certainly
be healed by the time they go to Denver
for him to fly there so he's not in the
back row of a greyhound of leaning up
against the window like ratso Rizzo not
everybody's talking at him you know I
mean it's that's that that's like planes
trains and author of a hardship because
clearly he's got the ability to stretch
out on a comfortable bed at or whatever
it works bleep if he wants to and he's
got all the video he can watch he told
me that he was watching TV and watching
tapes so so he'd take apparently like
lazy Friday night at home with a free
dinner it's lemming did he take it back
- yes yeah
as a matter of fact I wrote this morning
Ridge said if you read this column early
that deshaun Watson is probably on a bus
on his bus somewhere in East Texas a
couple hours I'm getting home to you oh
man a few more minutes left here with
Peter King it's amazing Peter how things
were
with the Ravens and Bengals losses the
Steelers now lead the AFC North coming
out of their bye week taking on
Cleveland it's now time to throw the
spotlight back on levy on bail with the
trade deadline coming up next Tuesday
how do you see it all playing out here
with loving on Peter you know rich I
talked to two teams over the weekend
that I thought might be interested in
trading for bail but the biggest issue
that they saw both teams saw this that
let's say for example they could find
some way reasonably to pry Le'Veon Bell
loose like trading a three and a five
and he could be on the team the rest of
the year well you know it's clear that
the agent and Bell want to maximize his
contract in 2019 so there's no guarantee
at all that he would just say at the end
of this season
hey Team X let's make the best deal we
can they don't want to do that they want
to make the best deal they can with one
of 32 teams or 31 teams not with your
team necessarily so you know let's say
for the sake of argument that you can't
get a contract done well obviously
you're going to franchise them and then
or transition them at least and then
you're in the exact same situation he
was in this year is he even going to
report to you so you're almost it's so
hard to trade for them knowing that you
might only have them on your team
because you can't you probably are not
putting them in the lineup this week or
next week you might only have another
team for like seven games though I mean
it's it's I I can't see the Steelers
being able to trade them unless it's an
absolute total dump job you know like
they trade them for a three or something
like that I just I can't see it and then
they take on the Browns and Hugh Jackson
says he wants to take control of the
offense more that that's his area of
expertise and this is the week that they
go back to Todd Haley's old shop I mean
how is that conversation going down with
Todd Haley and Hugh Jackson for
that's two four and one right now this
is not like this is not like if you are
a if you're a defensive coordinator and
you go to work for Bill Belichick let's
say even though he doesn't do it this
way you know you know that the guy who's
your boss who's your head coach that's
his area of expertise so if he steps
into your room you just got to take it I
mean whether Todd Haley likes it or not
Hugh Jackson has been an offensive
coordinator he's been a head coach in
two places and he's run offenses you
know in three different places so I find
it hard to believe that Todd Haley would
stomp his feet and and act childish if
Hugh Jackson said listen I want to do
more of X Y & Z whatever that may be and
I bet he's going to do that and Todd
Haley is just gonna have to take it and
he may not like it but and and again you
may hear because I have no idea what his
reaction would be
you might hear that he would be upset by
it but what do you expect to happen when
you're slumping on offense and when
you're head coach has his neck on the
line for his future because if they keep
losing games they're firing you Jackson
you know so what do you expect them to
do sit sit idly by and and lose all
these games and finish three twelve and
one and ride off into the sunset and the
only job you can get is as a quarterback
coach the rest of your career
I I mean to me I I think you Jackson has
every right in the world to do what he
wants great stuff here this is so much
fun thanks for the call we'll chat again
soon no problem Rick I'll see ya do you
got it that's Peter King the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience